hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and just checking in on you oh I
[ __ ] finally figured out my new
Olympus LS 100 I went back down to B and
H because I'm going to be interviewing
mom be doing a couple episodes of
uninformed with Joe DeRosa which is now
going to be up on YouTube is where we're
going to be put on my youtube channel
and and I'm also gonna be interviewing
Justin Long which I think will be the
Monday morning podcast who does have the
voice of Kevin Murphy on f is for family
one of my favorite people that I've met
in this business so I'll be talking to
him so I had to figure out a way to make
this whole thing work here you know I
finally had to stop just talking into
the mic so I apologize for all the
[ __ ] poor quality of the I apologize
to anybody that was triggered or
offended by the poor audio and whatnot
of the the DD DD past podcast but now I
can hear myself I got my headphones in I
got the [ __ ] mic Jack I got it in
stereo oh and I don't even need a
[ __ ] mix any more I am so [ __ ]
happy I really am so anyways the
mustachioed freckled [ __ ] is back last
night last night I went on a little date
night with my lovely beautiful gorgeous
awesome wife and we got a little uh we
got some food right before we went out
to go see burn this with Adam driver
Keri Russell David fer and Brandon
Aronowitz I hope I said his last name
right really blown away by the acting in
it and I don't know I'll get to that in
a minute so we go out to go we go out to
go to the dinner before the show because
when you go out to a Broadway show
you have to eat Midtown first and you
got to make reservations because
oh my god after about 6 o'clock all the
[ __ ] animals come in from the bridges
in the tunnels so when we went to some
place you know where they serve like
those you know portions that you should
be eating rather than American portions
I where you served me all is this fairy
food for I want a whole [ __ ] pig's
head on my goddamn plate and put some
taters on the side and some green [ __ ]
that ain't gay gave me a couple two
three pops of alcohol and I'm ready to
go see a Broadway play tapas I think is
what it's called I don't it was like a
[ __ ] wine bar there was a bunch of
gay dudes in there so you know the food
was gonna be good right
so we [ __ ] in there and we had this
great food and we'll laugh and we're
having a great time and everything and
we walked over to the theatre and we
ended up going to see this um we ended
up going to see you know it's funny to
be sitting in that bar with all those
gay guys and I got this [ __ ] giant
moustache and Nia called she called me
ready mercury and she immediately you
know almost spit her wine out after she
said it and she goes make sure you say
that on the podcast because I want to
see the mmm Photoshop do a picture of
you as freddy mercury with the big dumb
red moustache and I was like fair enough
fair enough
you know so we ended up walking over to
theater it was really awesome it's fun
to actually to go out to a theater and
not be the one that has to do a [ __ ]
show I was like oh yeah I forgot this is
fun did you see a theater I'm like yeah
geez I can't do my stupid act and to say
that Adam driver is a tour de force in
it is an understatement everybody in the
play was just I really enjoyed the whole
thing and and Adam drive was the guy was
familiar with and I'd seen him do other
things so I
we watching him be this guy and watched
him do a different walk watching him
have an accent and his mannerisms and
all of that everything was different
from the last thing that I saw him do
and ladies and gentlemen that is acting
all right that is acting okay there's so
many [ __ ] people comedians in general
that I talked to they go dude anybody
can [ __ ] act anybody can [ __ ] take
addicted no anybody can go on scream and
just basically say this [ __ ] and talk
the way you already talk and make it
sound believable you can do that that is
base level that would be the stand-up
equivalent to being at work and telling
a street joke at a [ __ ] water bubbler
but to then to change the way you walk
the way you talk your mannerisms the
whole thing and to become somebody else
that is acting I think you know and they
always have like these [ __ ] people
that don't act and then they go in a
movie they do a great job but they're
always put there playing themselves you
don't I mean like when the Chicot was
married to [ __ ] Kurt Cobain played a
[ __ ] out-of-control drug addict
everyone's like oh my god she was
amazing it was it that's what she's
doing every day she's crawling around on
the floor looking for that [ __ ] crack
rock I mean yeah she knows what she she
knows that's not acting anyway so look
at my acting work anyway so we ended up
having a great time and we hung out a
little bit afterwards got in late
paid for it this morning when a little
boo bear woke up who by the way went
potty for the first time which was
amazing all those all of those little
accomplishments are like amazing and
you're so proud of them and then you're
also sad because with each thing that
they can achieve and now do on their own
they're less connected to you you know
and believe it or not like changing
their diapers and stuff you get a lot of
good you know back and forth time you
know cause it's so such
balls of energy they've running around
so when you change that diaper they
actually do have to lay down for a
second and they start talking to you you
can crack some jokes and stuff it's
actually a lot of fun so I was as proud
as I was I was like ah now I'm not gonna
have that little moment anymore
let's get to the point she's almost
faster than me being a friggin old dad
but we we've been exploring all the new
york city parks out here and found
another new one that we went to and it
was crazy right as we were going to get
on the big jungle gym complex things
that they have you know cuz the kids are
out of school all these big kids just
like [ __ ] descended and they just take
over and they don't give a [ __ ] and you
know I don't know it's like you just you
and your little kid we're just gonna
have this great time and all of a sudden
this behemoths just like when Walmart
comes to town and puts all the
mom-and-pop stores out of business but
like the [ __ ] kid version of it and
my kids big she's tall right so but
she's still a little kid and sometimes
the big kids don't realize that one of
the big kids saw that she was still
wearing diapers
and she was going you kids just start
yelling you're not a baby you're not
baby you're not a baby and I swear to
God like I have to you know I just have
really have like I'm not good no
situations I need to learn adult coping
mechanisms because all I wanted to say
is like no she said she is still a baby
she's a toddler she says tall you
[ __ ] little [ __ ] stop yelling in her
face you know but like I see like you
can't do that so I just talked to my kid
via alright come on come on down the
slide come on down the slide you know
and then she goes down the slide like a
little kid and then one of those little
big [ __ ] starts coming right down I
gotta yank her out of the way like the
end of an action movie and my first hey
is Oh as I was I'm always like hey hey
hey and I try to calm it down you gotta
wait your turn and then they just look
at me and go who the [ __ ] this big
[ __ ] yelling at me it's like I'm like
yelling at you almost [ __ ] slammed
into my kid you know I don't know it
gets to be a bit much so then I then you
just sort of break off and then what
happens is then the toddler
go to where the [ __ ] they're supposed to
be at but um I don't know my kid enjoys
the [ __ ] what can I tell you but uh I
don't know it's been a it's been a good
week actually having the week off here
so I'm gonna take it to another park I'm
trying to get all the quality you know
dad kiddo Timon and I know it so I know
that you know all this shit's hard to
put into [ __ ] words it's hard to put
into words for the first time in your
life like feeling needed and I don't
mean like in a selfish way like oh good
I feel good because I feel needed I feel
the more like that fear of like this
[ __ ] kid like needs me has this need
and I'm the solution Jesus Christ a [ __ ]
do I live up to this so I think that
that's why I start overreacting is some
some kids think it was just yelling [ __ ]
but I just like I don't know it takes me
back to when I was a kid and it's and
it's I guess I can't even say the [ __ ]
anymore because it's so [ __ ] a
politically correct time you know at
some point there's a way that you as a
kid you got to handle a situation like
that so that kid moves on to some other
kid you know that for some reason has
been I don't know they got that thing
now I'm not saying this kid was like
that but they got this whole [ __ ]
thing now where they think they feel
like they can sit down and talk to
bullies and then bullies us they're
gonna stop being bullies and it's just
like there are some kids that are just
[ __ ] [ __ ] and your kid needs to
learn how to handle that not across that
bridge and you know it's no secret to
what the solution is let's get off that
subject I had I think the best pizza
I've ever had in my life
and I'm gonna have to go back to Frank
Pepe's to see if this is true but I
finally got out to de pharah pizza in
Brooklyn and I got a regular slice
and what up what they used to call a
Sicilian slice where I was from but they
call it a grandma slice other people do
down here I got one of each with a
[ __ ] root beer and yeah it was I
don't know what they do with that pizza
there was something in the dough that
just added to the perfect combination of
sauce and cheese and whenever I go to a
place I always make sure I always just
get the plane cuz Pete you can hide
behind toppings and everything and it
was funny people on the movie had
mentioned you know that I go there
because I did a little run making fun of
New York Pizza not saying it was bad but
just saying how much of it is bad
because everybody's living off the
reputation of it so they got defensive
and they told me to go out there and it
was weird right as they told me to go
out there I saw Dave Portnoy el pres on
barstool sports did a review of it and
you know it's very hard to get into the
eights with that guy and he gave it a 9
for and was eating it and he just kept
going wow wow that's that's a good slice
Wow he just kept saying that I was like
all right so I know that that's a
[ __ ] 10 but he's like the Rex Reed of
pizza review remember Rex Reed on the
gong show where he was like too mean to
give a 10 that's kind of the vibe I get
from because someone's ever gotten a 10
no maybe there would be the sadness that
if so you give somebody a 10 the quest
is over and you stop eating pizza I
don't know what but all I know is when
Dave Portnoy gives something to 94 I'm
[ __ ] going to it so I went down there
and it was it was amazing go down there
during the week to when there's that a
bunch of long lines or any of that [ __ ]
you know just jump on the I jumped on
the train from the Upper West Side I
mean it took me like maybe a half hour
totally [ __ ] worth it and I hope to
be definitely going back there again
I gotta wait though so I'm doing this
friggin thing here
so I got a I got a I got a space it out
oh look who's here Nate Nia come here I
told him your joke what did you call me
with my moustache what was your
reference I forgot he's a rock star
already mercury come over yeah come on
the podcast Jesus I got my I got my
whole thing fixed here this sound is
good and everything did you enjoy the
play last night I did I really did it
was awesome
how great was everybody in that thing
huh Adam driver coming in toward a force
Adam driver came in like a rocket ship
Adam who and he was amazing he was
amazing we're both [ __ ] tired I am so
not even and I'm not funny on this thing
- yeah getting like six hours sleep I
can't do it anymore yeah I should have
taken a nap before I did this thing
alright you go you're gonna go go work
out yep that's it he has been crushing
it by the way crushing it crushing it I
look like I'm the one who had the baby
now what is going on with this [ __ ]
thing now come on I finally had it all
set up
everything was good oh I got it so I
went I did some spots the other night
the other thing I don't like about this
this thing is it's so friggin hard to
tell how much time is left I press that
button re I did a couple spots the other
night I did Caroline's and then I did
Gotham and I did the exact same material
and on one show I kind of bombed and
then the next one I did go but I think
is I went on after this comic who's
really funny but for the most part I
feel he worked clean so maybe I just was
coming up there sounding like a
foul-mouthed [ __ ] but this guy Lukas
O'Neill went up did a great job
a bunch of great bits I didn't get a
chance to say hello to him I kind of ran
out of it because I was just like he's
crowd [ __ ] hates me for the most part
they were laughing but I swear to God I
was looking at the crowd and I wasn't
more than like three sentence in in this
woman in a crowd she had her hands on
either side of her head like she was
watching like like like to cover a home
alone she's like in her 20s and I'm just
looking at it like what in the [ __ ]
could I possibly be saying that gets
like that level reaction I got to tell
you I've almost been doing this [ __ ] for
30 years I've never said anything on
stage that ever got a reaction like that
and she had the [ __ ] look on her face
and then there was another woman older
woman by older I mean like my age and
she was just sitting there with like her
mouth a gate and I know there's just two
of them reacting that way that I should
be looking but what am i [ __ ] saying
it's not me it's not me I want to be
like you people [ __ ] changed not me
well maybe I'm going a little bit harder
cuz everybody's [ __ ] overreacting but
it was like actually throwing me off
during my set if you ever want like like
as far as like they weren't even
heckling but they were heckling just put
the expressions on their faces I'm
trying to think what I want I did I did
a my usual [ __ ] then I went to the
abortion bit then I did the Michael
Jackson thing sorry guys I'm putting
together new hours so there's gonna be
some pretty broad topics here I don't
know what happened and I and they so
[ __ ] like there was even a guy going
oh this guy's going on oh he was older
than me it's like what do you mean uh-oh
like what the [ __ ] you've been doing
your whole life you you you [ __ ] were
born in the 1950s there's no [ __ ] way
anything that I'm saying
I don't know I can't wait for this whole
[ __ ] time to be over and it is gonna
be
/ because you know why I'm gonna [ __ ]
I'm gonna I'm gonna humming humming I'm
gonna Pat myself on the naughty I don't
know what I'm gonna do I'm I [ __ ]
really justify my thing here I [ __ ]
travel the country and I talked to
[ __ ] people I know where their goddamn
heads are at and this stupid ass [ __ ]
horseshit where they're censoring
everybody and everybody's acting like
the [ __ ] sky is falling because a
[ __ ] comedian is telling a goddamn
joke and then meanwhile they just turn a
[ __ ] blind eye on the carnage of war
every [ __ ] night because they don't
even show it on the goddamn news and
that's not a problem that's not a
[ __ ] problem okay a drone strike
hitting a family of five because you
thought they were bad guys and then
they're not hey [ __ ] whatever to that
[ __ ] thoughts and prayers
you know bla bla ba ba ba and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then I go on stage
and give some stupid [ __ ] horseshit
about my version of [ __ ] of the
abortion they look at me like I just
overturned Rovi wave and I'll tell you
right now I'm getting me my mustache
you're getting sick of it every [ __ ]
night I got to sit there and I got it I
got to do my little stupid silly little
pep talk on on why you shouldn't be
shocked at what the [ __ ] I'm saying but
then they always laugh and then they
kind of come along for the ride I got a
quick little line that I say that that I
don't want to get into what it is
because then you're gonna know what it
is then when I go there you gonna be
yelling it out with me so I don't I
don't [ __ ] know I don't know all
right but I'm going on stage and they're
making me feel like I'm singing doo-wop
around a goddamn burning trash can
that's what I feel like every night like
that I become old overnight you know I
saw this whole article that this [ __ ]
ridiculous article that this person is
writing about a stand-up comic you know
going you know if the if the comedy club
books this person they don't care about
the safety of the waitstaff it's just
like it's just such [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just such it's just it is the it's
being in that scene and just being there
and then listen to this [ __ ]
person's perception of what the [ __ ] is
going on down at the comedy club it's
just an outright [ __ ] lie it's no
different than when you read the [ __ ]
New York Post or the Daily News and they
are just spinning it towards their
[ __ ] political agenda and it's just
outright [ __ ] lies they'll hold the
hope of the climate and all of this [ __ ]
that they're presenting it's like what
research did you even [ __ ] do on this
it's just you don't want this person to
come back there for it what you're now
gonna do is make just write these
[ __ ] crazy lies about the Hulk
stand-up comedy scene so you can try and
get this traction so what you want to
have happen can [ __ ] happen it's so
it's so [ __ ] up it's so [ __ ] up in
it because it is lies and all of that
you know I probably shouldn't get worked
up and I probably shouldn't you know
throw any gas on the fire but it's just
I don't know it's just it's just
outright [ __ ] lies and it's all like
political agenda and what these people
want to have happen even like when
they'll do like the I was telling
another comic and they were talking
about like you know the comedy power
issue and all of that and it was it was
just totally a political agenda the
amount of absolute [ __ ] monsters that
they ignored and I'm not going to name
names because I don't put anybody into
this [ __ ] thing but there's literally
like you know this podcasters out there
that you can do you can do their show
and you're going to get more people
hearing you than if you went and did the
entire [ __ ] late-night talk show
circuit and they completely ignored them
because they didn't fit into their
progressive agenda of what they want the
entertainment landscape to look like
which is fine I don't give a [ __ ] about
that but don't just [ __ ] lie and and
this is what the power it's not what it
looks like I don't know I don't know
well I would at whatever so I I actually
I should just find the [ __ ] humor in
it and just be like oh so you guys are
lying pieces of [ __ ] to for your own
[ __ ] agenda and with that let's move
on to the next the next portion of the
goddamn program here let's let me Street
up a little bit of advertising here I
got one read left alright one read this
week helix HELOCs I want to know the
secret to a good night's sleep will do
yeah a clear conscience and the right
mattress well I can't help you fix
things you've done we've got the
mattress covered with helix helix sleep
headaches built a sleep quiz that takes
two minutes to complete and they use
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper a
hot sleeper gross like a plush or firm
bed with helix helix there's no more
guessing or compromising just go to
helix sleep calm slash bar take their
two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match
you to the mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life four couples
hellix can even split the mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
helix sleep was even awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2019
by GQ & Wired magazine and CNN called it
the most comfortable mattress they've
ever slept on well they're a 24-hour
news network I didn't think they ever
slept they have a 10 year warranty and
can get you and you get to try it out
for a hundred nights gross risk-free
right now hellix leap is offering up to
125 dollars off mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 125 dollars off
helix sleep calm / / that's hellix sleep
calm / / for up to $125 off your order
he likes sleep calm / / h e li
you know I've been following baseball a
little
more now that we're you know the hockey
and the basketball is done and I got to
tell you the [ __ ] Yankees are tearing
it up Red Sox went seven and three and
still dropped two games to the Yankees
however we are we are gaining on whoever
the [ __ ] is in second place I forget did
you see how that they're talking about
possibly having they're exploring the
Tampa Bay Devil Rays being the being the
Tampa sorry the Tampa Bay Rays I don't
offend anybody down there in Joel
Olsteen country I ain't trying to say
let Satan is the reason why you've never
won the World Series but wouldn't it be
the reason wouldn't they sell their
souls to win that trophy isn't that what
they would do and then devil would
double-cross them and stick them in that
little [ __ ] I actually like their
stadium Tropicana Field but anyways
they're saying half half the half the
year they'd be the Tampa Bay Devil Rays
Rays and then the other half they'd go
play in Montreal and become what the the
Expos the Montreal Devil Rays the
Montreal Rays I don't know it seems to
me like they're just gonna move them to
Montreal doesn't know what that seems
that's like when you're in a
relationship and people say we're taking
a break it's like no you're breaking up
we need to take a break I was always
excited when a woman said to him that
before I met my wife Nia if a woman said
we need to take a break I was like oh
good we're breaking up good because I
don't know how to be in one of these are
we taking a break okay great so we'll
talk to each other every day then every
other day and then
yeah it'll just fade away so I think
would be great
it'd be great if they went back to
Montreal because it's still [ __ ] up
that they didn't win that the World
Series in 1994
let's look up that roster shall we this
and [ __ ] sports nerd [ __ ] that i like
to do montreal expos 1994 roster i know
they had pedro martinez yeah look at
this [ __ ] this is what this was this was
their [ __ ] this was their lineup I'm
just going to name the ones that I they
had cliff Floyd Moises Alou Larry Walker
after I'd recognized more names they
always talk about they had Pedro
Martinez now wait a minute I thought Tim
Raines was still on there wasn't he
still on there and I also thought
what's-his-face just spaced up Pedro
what's-his-face
he ended up on the angels wait a minute
Pedro Guerrero Burnett Guerrero was that
[ __ ] would not Vladimir Guerrero
he wasn't on that [ __ ] team the [ __ ]
out of here put it this way Pedro
Martinez was a number two pitcher wait a
minute
where the [ __ ] are all the guys I
thought was on that team always thought
Randy Johnson was on that team he wasn't
on the team Pedro Martinez was [ __ ]
27 years old wait there was only one
hall-of-famer on that team so what the
[ __ ] does everybody always talk about
how loaded they were I thought Vlad
Guerrero was on there I thought Tim
Raines was winding down his career wait
a minute
Vladimir Guerrero I can't spell it okay
Guerrero and what do you really go to
you go to the [ __ ] baseball
encyclopedia just write stats the [ __ ]
did he come in the league now they got
you Vlad Guerrero jr. know the [ __ ]
areas there he is
Oh first year was 96 yeah you know what
I don't you know something if you've
learned anything this podcast I need
eight hours sleep and I also don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about all
right maybe I was wrong about the power
issue maybe maybe I need to adjust what
I'm doing onstage so I can become part
of the power issue there's no power in
making somebody do the home alone face
bill you know you shouldn't be in the
power issue when the LOL comedy club
doesn't know who you are by the way i
can't believe every [ __ ] comic i
walked up to was talking to you about
that story i thought i'd i hope i told
it in a funny way I wasn't upset about
it
I was upset that he then had to go
downtown downtown comedy club I had to
go downtown to go to a [ __ ] spot
because I was tired and I'm an old man I
just wanted to roll in there and do a
[ __ ] spot you know but now there's
people out there that's saying allegedly
that comedy club doesn't pay people I
don't know if that's true or not or it
only pays like the [ __ ] headline or
whatever so now I'm thinking well [ __ ]
maybe it's a good thing that I didn't go
up in there I don't know
anyways Jesus Christ is all the dadoes I
[ __ ] Vladimir Guerrero is a young dad
the guy's only 44 years old and his son
is already in Major League Baseball
Vladimir Guerrero jr. let's click on
this guy how old is this guy Vlad
Guerrero jr. he also plays for a
Canadian team how crazy is that he was
born in 1999 so his dad was 24 years old
he's 20 years old isn't that something
Jesus Christ um anyway alright well you
know as excited as I was that I was
really just gonna rip on this podcast I
just I feel like I was the butt of the
jokes I feel like I was the person and
the wrong yeah I was the person in the
wrong guy
anyways I told you a good place to get
some pizza even know Dave Portnoy
already told you that I learned that the
montreal 1994 for montreal expos maybe
it might be a little overhyped
considering they only have one
hall-of-famer on there Tim Raines was
already gone
Vladimir Guerrero was not there yet nor
was his son conceived alright so that's
a big over 3 cliff Floyd was there they
had cliff Floyd that was somebody that I
reckon alright was that the Crime Dog is
that the guy I don't [ __ ] know it's
all you know what it's all blending
together so anyways I'm gonna go take my
kid to the park that's what I do
I'm gonna go yawn and take my kid to the
park you know what I'm gonna I'm not
gonna flip out when the big kids come
I don't yeah I kind of muttered I told
you that you know at one time I did I
didn't yell I just sort of muttered I
think I think I call the kid a fat [ __ ]
I muttered it
he came up and he just sort of you know
push my kid out of the way no not a push
push sort of a you know the way security
guides somebody out of the way
you know and my daughter was like you
know she does her she's younger so she
thinks she can't like run up to the
slide sit down and go down on as fast as
the bigger kids this kid didn't want to
wait and yeah I just said hey hey hey
wait your turn I go you [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
I kind of muttered that underneath and I
looked at one of his friends was staring
at me I was just like Jesus Christ and
then when the kid got off he whispered
something to the the fat [ __ ] kid and
then they were both staring at me giving
me the [ __ ] stink eye and it's just
like all right I'm that guy
I gotta own it I'm that guy I'm that guy
with the mustache Kirstin in front of
little kids I got I think that's a
normal reaction job anybody else out
there a parent and he goes let me I you
on it I want to hear your [ __ ] horror
stories too going to the park so and
give me some advice on how to keep your
cool when the [ __ ] big kids
specifically the boys show up goddamn
Braveheart they come over the [ __ ]
hill and just descend on whatever they
want to do and they just push people out
of the way and all of this and how mad
can I get cuz at one point I was that
kid granted most of the time I was
getting chased down the hill by the
other kids you know just being a you
know they were they were they were
looking back I feel like all those kids
that bullied me were just jealous of my
exotic good looks alright we all know
that that's not true I did fine I made
him laughing and he and they stop
[ __ ] with me it was essentially it
you know we moved around a little bit as
a kid you know so I had I had to [ __ ]
hit the reset button a few times but by
the third time I knew what I was doing
you know and then everything was fine
for a while for a while I think I don't
know but this isn't this isn't time for
therapy all right I'm taking my kid to
the park please enjoy the music all
right and then there's gonna be another
half-hour of a greatest hits Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast if you're in New York go
check out burn this I think they're
running through mid July
and I'd like to do more [ __ ] like that I
guess the theater that we want to go
that where it's playing at which of
course I already forget begins with an M
is it them I don't think it's a majestic
I know what the [ __ ] it is but it's one
of the oldest theaters in New York City
and someone in the cast was telling me
that the original Tonight Show taped
there and the original price is right
two of my favorite shows of all time how
[ __ ] cool is that and it's a
beautiful theater I've never been in one
where they had the seats were covered in
and like the the material the color was
gold and it really worked like the whole
theater popped it was [ __ ] gorgeous I
don't know I'd love to do a show there
at some point but I think they just do
the Broadway stuff so who knows alright
anyway
that's it that's the podcast have a
great weekend you [ __ ] and I will talk
to you on Monday
[Music]
all right last week our Monday I should
say I read this
we had the heading to an email question
and we did not have the email and Ruth
emili´s apologizes profusely and I had
to stop him from committing Harry Caray
all right lady needing advice don't want
to go to males friend's wedding hey Bill
I really enjoy the advice portion of
your podcast and could use an objective
opinion I am a lady and have a male
friend that I've been friends with since
I was 10 years old I'm now 29 you know
what guys I got to apologize something I
have this great bit I can't wait to try
out tomorrow night
and I literally was thinking about the
joke I wanted to do and how far I was
gonna take it while I read all of that
so I have no idea what's going on this
email just please forgive me as I reread
this I am a lady and have a male friend
that I've been friends with what you
just said you were friends I have a male
friend that I've been enemies with I
have a male friend that I've been
friends with since I was 10 years old
I'm 29 now okay so you've been friends
with this guy for 19 years now geez did
he think of bringing you back in the
seventh grade my friend is with this
girl that I've never warmed up to she's
a [ __ ] now wait a minute did you always
think he was gonna ask you is that what
it is maybe they don't know but he just
read the [ __ ] thing she's a bit
condescending phony and I just don't
like her he's he's in his early 30s
she's 25 she's got you on the old
odometer there and they both currently
live with his mom who also happens to be
a good friend of mine they have crappy
jobs don't pay his mom rent or
contribute much but instead they're
putting money back to have a wedding by
the end of the year
I love my friend but he's always been a
bit immature when it comes to money
responsibilities why are you still
hanging out with these people you these
people sound like [ __ ] losers walk
away be thankful you didn't hit your
wagon to this [ __ ] I can tell you right
now if you were with this guy and you
were living in his mom's house you would
not be friends with his mom anymore
you'd be like I got to get the [ __ ] out
of here anyways they're not they're
immature when it comes to money
responsibility or what it takes to be an
adult he still depends on his mom a lot
he's 32 this is pathetic
I don't hear a dad in this scenario here
we did he not have a dad he didn't learn
how to be a mom be a man I should say
mom when my grandmother recently died I
was devastated he asked me for my my
address I thought I would get a sympathy
card but instead I got a save the date
card oh my god that's sad and [ __ ]
hilarious
it pisses me off that he's a bit of a
selfish prick in his own world and also
a dumbass for being in such a rush to
get married when neither one of them has
their [ __ ] together it's difficult for
me to be supportive before you assume
I'm secretly in love with him which I
did I'm sorry our friendship has been
nothing but platonic and I recently got
married myself I'm sorry but this whole
thing read like When Harry Met Sally
except Harry never moved out I don't
want to go I don't want to go to their
wedding my question is do you think I
should put my shoe side and try to be
supportive of my friend since he's happy
I feel as though our friendship has
shifted a ton since he's been with this
girl and it's no longer easy talking to
him this is what you do you go to the
wedding and then you just gradually back
away you've outgrown these people okay
that's it you're married you have your
own [ __ ] life if he wants to live at
home with his mother with his new wife
whatever the [ __ ] it is is going to do
you just go there and just have a nice
smile on your face just being happy that
you're nothing on the other side of the
I do okay I'm still not a hundred
percent
buying the fact that you don't have some
sort of feelings for this kid who's now
still acting like a kid in his 30s
you're 29 he's 32 he was three years
older you probably said this is perfect
then you envisioned him wearing a suit
and coming home Britain like Hugh
Beaumont at the beginning of Leave It to
Beaver with a higher end [ __ ] GM
product Oldsmobile possibly a Buick who
knows I don't know but this is what I
would do you got to let it go it wasn't
meant to be okay and even if you don't
have romantic feelings for this person
all right if you don't have feelings for
this [ __ ] person I can already tell
you the fact that it's so driving you
nuts that you had to write into some
dope like me doing a podcast I don't
know the way the way this is all written
I think you weigh your feelings on your
sleeve and they're gonna know what's up
I would go there you know smile a wave
that's it and then I would not torture
your husband on the way home or the
whole night critiquing them about how
[ __ ] stupid it is because I can tell
you this right now your husband doesn't
want to [ __ ] go so what you should go
you should do is you should go there and
you should have a great [ __ ] time
with your husband and you should thank
him for not being a [ __ ] loser that
lives at home with this mom
there you go all right and then go to
frame bridge take a picture your tits
and give it to them on Sunday that's the
podcast everybody
god bless all you god bless america and
that's it get off the internet go sit on
the stoop and go make some music with
your friends stop taking life so [ __ ]
seriously stay away from credit cards
stay away from the meth your doctor
prescribes any painkillers that has any
opiates in it do not take him tough it
out just watch there will be blood did
she sit down the contrary
toughing it out [ __ ] guy dragged
himself out of the [ __ ] Wiley coyote
mind with a broken leg to go in town
just to get a [ __ ] gold nickel all
right you can do it all right that's the
podcast have a great weekend your
constant I'll talk to you on Monday
[Music]
so fuzzy is completely addicted to
skating now and he wants to get better
at it and so we're [ __ ] in Edmonton
the next morning we got drive down to
Calgary and parsees going like there's
got to be a place here to skate so we
find out they have they have a skating
rink at the mall and not only is it a
mall it's one of the most giant malls in
North America Amerika yeah
West Edmonton rivaling what's that one
in Minnesota Mall of America Mall of
America yeah yeah so which I've been to
that one too so we go to that one we're
walking through there with her [ __ ]
skates two middle-aged guys walking
through this thing with [ __ ] skates
and we walk in there's like this giant
pirate ship I mean like yeah you could
sail the [ __ ] ocean with this [ __ ]
thing yeah it was a [ __ ] official and
I look on the other side it was really
deep water and they took all this time
to make it look like there was a
shipwreck Jesus cry me like you could
[ __ ] you know it was monstrous yeah
like Shaq could drown in this water if
he didn't that's how [ __ ] deep it was
huge and then we look on the other side
and I'm like Paul Mike is that a [ __ ]
sea lion
they had sea lions at this thing they're
like thrown at fish fishing it was
catching trainer was don't there wasn't
like people just walking by throwing
[ __ ] from the food court it was a
trainer throwing it and so we're just
walking through the mall walking through
the mall endless [ __ ] well they had a
water park there yeah it was since I
didn't look at any stores I was too
distracted by the [ __ ] in the middle and
then we finally get all the way to the
ice palace they called it ice palace and
we got all excited and we're the only
people with skates just walking through
holding a [ __ ] dumb skates and we get
all the way to the other side Rosy's all
excited like dude I'm telling you I'm
gonna get better at this you wait this
summer he's already talking [ __ ] they're
calling it right now I'm gonna be
[ __ ] skating backwards you're gonna
be like what the [ __ ] happened virzi
yeah right and then we show up and
there's a big judo tournament where the
ice rink is and they'd [ __ ] put all
this floor flooring all over maybe this
isn't a rink
they might acknowledge dude it says ice
palace ball this is it they covered it
up this is it I got upset though at the
mom a member girl man I really bothered
me
walking through the food court and you
know I we had a gyro great gyro as you
play oh yeah yeah a great gyro at this
place called Jimmy the Greek the one
complaint and you agreed a little too
much white sauce and it was pasty yeah
it wasn't it wasn't yeah it was a little
pasty just not one scoop he went to want
one scoop lesson a little hot sauce
excited he got excited it would have
been epic yeah we got excited so then I
said to Bill you know I like a little
dessert after I eat you know I like a
little candy bar I like a little you
know sugar so so I go bill man it was
the frozen yogurt place
oh yeah Pinkberry if somebody said girls
go for frozen yogurts you all right so
we're walking like I hate the picture so
two middle-aged men with skates I know I
don't like how you keep saying I'm
middle-aged you are middle-aged I'm 30 I
just turned 35 35 times to 70 most guys
[ __ ] drop my car I call like I call
middle it yeah all right what would you
call it
no I guess you're right I guess you know
I always just when I thought of it as a
kid I always felt you know it was no I
don't know I just remember dude I it's I
don't know we'll just say 40 40s but I
you know boardies 40 people do people
live long yeah dude I'm [ __ ] be 46 46
times 2 is 92 you're gonna really I
can't really sit there and say I'm
middle-aged I'll tell you the way I'm
eating and smoking you know no so so we
walk through and we're like where's that
where was that frozen yogurt place let's
go to that frozen yogurt place so we -
we see two young women walk by and we
figure hey I looked at them and I'm like
these these these ladies they're gonna
know we're if they're gonna know we're a
Pinkberry is so we walk up and you go
first you say to the friend you go hey
you got you guys know what that could
they're good-looking too by the way yeah
good good looking girls and you go up
first people hey you guys know where the
frozen yogurt places and like she did
like a double take like she did a double
take so [ __ ] rude right and she just
was like what and then I looked at the
other one and I go yeah like a Pinkberry
and she kind of just like gives a shake
off like how would I know like why you
and she [ __ ] did this is what she did
she did the classic pretty girl you're
clearly just asking me this because you
want to talk to me thing and I'm like no
[ __ ] I want some [ __ ] yogurt okay I
want [ __ ] I want to [ __ ] treat you
no I just had
and it really bothered me dude and we
were walking around and I wanted to find
her I wanted to walk past this again
they did the loop on the front I didn't
know that but I said to Bill when we got
to the car I wanted to find it cuz I
would've just want to know you know
something I found it near a mean jerk
and then you go why would you do that
you're a mean jerk that's terrible what
am I gonna call her a [ __ ] well don't
call her anything if you're gonna go
with mean jerk I mean you know I hate
that girl mentality that pretty girls
say you're mean but you're a jerk if you
want to stay clean but if you go you're
a mean jerk no you know you're not
pretty inside
you're not pretty inside doesn't give a
[ __ ] she's the hot girl at the mall put
yourself in her [ __ ] pumps all right
we're to [ __ ] lock her jackasses
standing there with ice skates when
there's a judo tournament down the way
asking if they know where the [ __ ]
the ice cream store is they looked at
it's the way they were supposed to I you
know what dude I like a sweetheart yeah
I don't care I would love to hear them
tell this story and me coming and it's
just creepy guy comes up like you know
that's the way they're gonna hear it
Paul Paul you ever watch those [ __ ]
prison shows which ones like the scared
straight no not those ones where they
talk about the worst prisons in the
country and that type of [ __ ] oh yeah
I've seen a couple of yeah and you just
sit there watching it going how the [ __ ]
would I go in there and not get raped
what would my game plan you get scared
watching it in your bedroom right women
have to walk out of the house worried
about that that somebody's gonna you
know do just imagine if dude I had a
winter hat on with a puffy ball on top
of it holding ice skates asking for
yogurt Gaby if anything she probably
thought I was [ __ ] gay you don't look
gay Paul I know but you're not uestion
not you your beards to terrorists you're
you need to get a little more
metrosexual I do that we would switch
sweatpants on do we were a mess
everybody in the [ __ ] girl yeah
that's what you love my beard my beard
actually [ __ ] says everybody on the
[ __ ] ground no but dude I I don't
like the pretty girl who can't be
approached with a question because oh
this guy's hitting on me it's it's awful
and you know something the gut
especially the blonde one who went like
shook her head like what she's gonna be
a nightmare
she's a [ __ ] nightmare for some
future guy I'm telling you she's a
nightmare
she's already selfish it's over what if
she just knows what she wants and we're
not it oh this is the thing dude you
actually allowed like how old do you
think they were probably twenty-one
twenty-two yeah you look at 21 22 year
old I met a girl at my age not even a
one way she shaking or letter you let
her ruin like two we're driving down to
Calgary she ruins I got the Rocky
Mountains on the right-hand side of the
car and you're just still calling you're
calling her a [ __ ] the whole way down
the [ __ ] out of me it was like why are
you why would you ask me how would I
know
dude you realize how funny that is that
they did that to us like what like yeah
they really made us feel like [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hilarious if you look at
it it bothered and the whole time is cuz
you wanted to get frozen yogurt dude how
funny would it be if we chased him down
and you got frozen yogurt with sugarfree
gummy bears ha it was still all-natural
no organic gummy bears how great would
it be if we chased him down and I just
walked up to her and I go you know
something you hurt my feelings by the
way people listening here this is last
week you know you know just trying to
kill just trying to make jokes do not go
out of your mind being on tour this
[ __ ] long yeah is we were doing the
Dangerfield's everything I'll tell you I
got a friend of my love yogurt you know
so we were doing that and once that went
away that got old somewhere along the
line you started doing it you started
saying really sentimental [ __ ] to me and
then pretending like you were crying and
then that just became like the running
joke and then you started laughing and
then you were just like you got to do
that on stage do that crime thing so now
we'll just go up and like if we'll be
like hey man I'm tired but dude you know
what hanging with you on the road has
been great come and tag it that's the
best thing bill would come and check it
out
but it's been it's been [ __ ]
wonderful for my anger I'm gonna try to
do that when I get home
you don't attend like I'm crying man
it's [ __ ] hilarious
so two stories we go in to eat and we
have this Filipino waiter right by the
way
I like to play the games where I sorta
hell where we was that Edmonton was that
Calgary that was Abington yeah was
Edmonton so I like to do this thing
where sometimes I like to [ __ ] with
people so I'll just get on a phone and
I'll be like bill go along with it
and I'll be in an elevator and I'll go
what no that's horseshit and like bill
just look what happens so like I said
like yeah the parole officer called and
he said in Pilger so they worked it up
and then instantly burgos yeah but what
about that videotape I go no no they
said it since immiscible and like and
like there's just a stranger there right
sometimes I break out laughing so bill
calls it he gets a little emotional guy
so we turned this crying thing we do it
too like this has been great right we
turn that into doing it in public so we
have this Filipino waiter right and the
whole guy was great he was talking to us
and at the end I just go he goes here's
your bill and I go I just want to say so
and I kept the dead straight face like
you've been a great waiter man and I put
my hand on his [ __ ] arm you know
you're bringing the waters just bill
just looks out of those he gets a little
I guess a little emotional you know I
mean I had no because he was so [ __ ]
polite and he was actually from the
Philippines so he jumped right in
perfectly dead Freni gets a little
emotional I cannot Billy
he'd bring the waters he was freaked out
though no that's the new game on the
road you had the bessel and I gotta say
the best one was at the airport
yesterday we go to the airport yesterday
and Bill starts busting my balls about
my laundry and he goes virzi [ __ ] 16
days in you're carrying you know dirty
socks and underwear and I go dude I go I
bought new ones you know the dirty ones
are tied up tight in an in a plastic bag
and the bill just goes your emotions
dude I [ __ ] could not walk I couldn't
walk and I had to stop pulling my
[ __ ] the bag I checked because we
were laughing so hard at work style
makes it makes it's [ __ ] great it's
driving our tour manager nuts oh yeah
that's the one thing yeah well because
women don't I see a guy getting
emotional like that it's just
well no cuz want some fries it's over
yeah like when I go out afterwards and
I'm taking pictures with people and
stuff I always come back I was just like
I got to tell you you know you I've seen
a lot of people do that you know doing
the picture thing but you got wives
she's going would you stop [ __ ] doing
that our wives are gonna go nuts
cuz you know the first thing i want i
see stays and you see your wife we're
just gonna go you got you got to set it
up with talking like you got to start
off normal like that you gonna say
something really sentimental to him so
they're almost crying and then you cry
which ruins their crying and I swear to
god you get slugged in the shoulder
which is all you really want oh [ __ ] 20
minutes in I'll tell you Paul you know
time really flies it's so fun this is
probably only funny to us but I don't
give a [ __ ] try it with your friends
well [ __ ] that if the game if the game
is called
he gets emotional and just walk into a
bar just have one of your friends start
hitting on a woman and then and then the
other friends got to go along yeah and
then just start swelling up and then the
other guy goes I'm sorry
he just gets emotional and you just got
to let the other person deal with it
dude you won at the [ __ ] Airport
where you walked up to that lady at the
couple of the little [ __ ] I sell gum
whatever the hell it is excuse me do you
have the one of the biggest no I broke
out of here hey man what are the biggest
condoms you got what's the biggest size
condoms you have I turn around and walk
the one you turned around and walked
away and I'm just staring at her and I'm
biting my tongue as hard as I can
to not laugh and then I just burst out
laughing and she said what and then when
you went to repeat it you to try to
point to it I lost it you lost it and
had to walk away punch-drunk out here
you know one of my favorite things in
this business was Opie from the Opie and
Anthony show was he had this thing that
he would do when guys would start crying
when they would play audio yeah oh my
god was [ __ ] his timing was perfect
every time
someone would be talking like retiring
from a sport like when Mike Schmidt
retired which is you know you it's very
difficult to watch news like you know
you know he just was ending his like 38
years ago a little boy began a journey
to play the wonderful game and that Opie
would always go oh boy
what am i favorite it always hopefully
it always made nobody wants to see a man
just completely you know what it is I
can watch a guy cry if something
terrible is happening just don't try to
talk while you're crying no that's the
thing the talking and then bursting out
into Christ let your shoulders go yeah
boom he's your [ __ ] crying but don't
[ __ ] for the love of God a man need all
time so a man needs to cry in private
yeah you do that in the shower you do it
in the shower like when my son was born
everyone's like did you cry yet and I'm
like no what are you talking about and
then when my son was born it all hit me
later and I went home to go get stuff
for my wife in the hospital and I sat on
the couch and I didn't like weep but I
just got I didn't weep but I got
emotional but like just fixing you sit
on the couch by yourself and just use
[Laughter]
completely unacceptable thank for your
podcast mercy effect it's unacceptable
dude on it completely hell you're right
doll to talk into it
right yeah to talk into it that's that's
what the find out about crying is you
know yeah you know you always do this to
me you know you always do this to me and
I'm trying my best
oh yeah it's [ __ ] over but none of my
friends died I've had so many who
[ __ ] died I just cry in the shower
yes what I do I asked a girl we asked a
girl right because you don't feel like
you're crying cuz there's all that water
on your face anyways no we asked a girl
we go what would you do if dude dude
started crying like if it wasn't if
nobody died if a dude and you were just
art he just had a bad day and he just
had a bad day and you got into it he
broke down and cry and she goes yeah no
over over over get the [ __ ] away from me
yeah you know what's funny there's some
women they think that they want to see
that part of you they don't get what
that is to them is that's their total
conquest yes you know when you bang a
girl in the ass you just like yeah I got
this [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] Jesus [ __ ] we do
their version of that is is if they can
get you to be so vulnerable around them
that you
cry and then it's one of those things
it's almost like when the crowd screams
out a joke they already heard they think
they want to hear it again and then you
tell it's like huh yeah it wasn't as
good
no it's the same thing is that yeah and
you said something you said something
about like if a burglar comes in if you
cry in front of a woman all in her mind
is like what if the burglar comes out
this [ __ ] guy ya know it's over you
can't cry you strip a woman of security
if you cry in front of her I think I
don't think I've cried I think my wife
so yeah that's a great that's what it is
yeah you strip her of her security
because now she's like why I got this
[ __ ] yeah this Ferenc crisis not just
baby sleeping next to me every night you
know yeah it's it's over you know I know
you just you might as I just have a
pullover sweater on you know and then
she mocks you what are you gonna cry
[ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] over dude
you can't have that have you ever cried
have you ever cried alone listening to a
song or like not cried but have you ever
been like oh no I'm completely broken
down and I've told her three cars just
weeping uncontrollably totally crying no
no I definitely teared up listen as an
as an artist at some point you're gonna
have to go to those emotions you need
you need to be you need to be in tune
with your instrument no I have what was
the ones like I had this weird thing
where I stopped crying at some point I
don't know when I stopped crying and got
mad more when when I got hurt and my
brother beat the [ __ ] out of me
you know that with it most the crying
I'd be just like the end of it but I
wasn't crying and then my brother's
bigger than me my little brother's
bigger than me right big though like and
I remember he I said I said if you
[ __ ] take my clothes again if you
take my clothes like he did it every day
he would go anywhere you take my belt he
would take my clothes and I'd come home
and I guess another boy band and I need
to go I need to go out right and I go
mom if he does it again
I'm [ __ ] hitting him if in my mom be
like ah you know he took and he and one
time I need really needed a shirt and
I'm [ __ ] still throwing [ __ ] through
the house and he gets out of his friends
and he starts walking up and he's got it
on and I [ __ ] snap them high
grandmother was there and I jumped on
him I started punching him and he stood
up he just goes wait you made your older
brother crying on my younger brother oh
he's bigger than me but he didn't know
what to do he got so upset that he just
got and he looked around he just he was
so angry that something needed to come
out and he just goes what did you feel
bad you started I kind of just walked
away and you know we left about it
afterwards but so now now he said he's a
[ __ ] he's a big kid but you know my mom
had the opposite I got a little brother
my he's an animal you know no my mom
said she went to a she went to a funeral
once and everybody was there and
everybody was crying and she was
overwhelmed with emotion that they had
to [ __ ] drag her out she said she had
them on one of the most embarrassing
things happened to her where she said
she uncontrollably laughed because they
said that that could happen sometimes so
she's sitting there she's she's sitting
there and everybody's crying and like
she went up and she could not stop
laughing and like she and I said why
like and she was like Paul I just don't
know she was I could not stop laughing
and I had to walk me out and like and
she's gone yeah she said because the
emotions were so much that they said
that could happen sometimes where it
just you just like she didn't know what
to do so instead of just breaking down
she went the other way
and just couldn't couldn't control her
say I know like humor like will protect
you and really like that's what they
don't get sometimes when comics make
[ __ ] horrific jokes about some bad
event make good jokes yeah it's about a
horrific event so they go that's oh [ __ ]
I mean it's a defense mechanism itself
my mom is it my mom is a sweetheart who
felt bad and her emotions just went the
other way and she goes Paul I felt so
bad if I couldn't control myself
control myself I hate to say this cuz
somebody lost somebody but there was if
there was video of that oh my god pops I
was saying so I somewhere around I don't
know 10 or 11 I didn't cry for years
years and years and years and I didn't I
didn't cry until a friend of mine killed
himself and even then I was sad and it's
just I went I was in the bathroom once
again yeah and it was in there and I
remember I started to cry and then I
started thinking like wow I'm crying
haven't cried in a long time and then I
because I get out of it cuz I stopped
thinking about the do kill himself Wow
yeah I went ten years without a cry and
then I had one what was it over yogurt
[Music]
no I think I might have been when my son
was born you know I might have been with
my sons that's acceptable a I guess it's
acceptable back in the day you just
stood on the way to room rank smoke a
cigar
[Music]
you